[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what's
on the front pages as they arrive and
it's time to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mirrors
associate editor Kevin McGuire and the
Daily Mail columnist Sarah fine they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight we'll speak to both of them in
just a moment but first let's see what's
on some of those front pages
the mail describes ITV as humiliated at
having to order an external inquiry into
Philip schofield's departure from this
morning
that story and allegations of a cover-up
also lead the mirror tomorrow
the eye carries analysis claiming
Labor's 20 billion pound raft of policy
proposals would cost the equivalent of a
3p income tax increase to an act
meanwhile the telegraph says Tori MPS
are telling Rishi sunak to scrap what
they call unfair inheritance tax rules
the Metro reports that the former
Russian president Dimitri Medvedev has
described senior British politicians as
legitimate targets given their support
for Ukraine
the times reports that Rishi sunak is
soliciting help from Turkey in Bulgaria
in his fight to stem the migrant small
boats crisis
the express reveals what it calls an Eco
mob plot to disrupt the running of the
famous horse race the derby
the guardian hears from the vice
chancellors of several UK universities
who believe that the way the higher
education system is funded is broken
the Ft tells us why it's soda ash which
is used to make glass could soon be
worth billions on the stock market
the sun leads with a story about Prince
Harry the fact that we haven't heard
much from him recently
and the star speaks to a Tudor historian
who claims Henry VIII didn't necessarily
deserve his bad reputation
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you're
watching us
and we're joined tonight by Kevin
McGuire and Sarah Vine let's kick off
shall we great to see you both thanks
for joining us um Sarah I'll kick off
with you first if I may front page of
the guardian of course one of those
stories that broke today Boris Johnson
has handed over all of his WhatsApp
messages
yes so there's been a big sort of debate
over the last few days about whether or
not uh the unredacted two years worth of
unreactive WhatsApp messages uh between
Boris Johnson and sort of I think it's
about 40 ministers civil servants
various people should be handed to the
covert inquiry
um the uh cabinet office who are in
charge of these things say no that
actually
um a lot of this stuff is relevant and a
lot of it is private and uh the person
in charge of the inquiry whose name I
temporarily forget baroness
you'd like to see everything and she'll
be the judge of that so there's been
this kind of ongoing row between the
cabinet office and and the code inquiry
and and now I think what's happened is
that Johnson himself has handed over a
whole load of messages if that's if am I
correct in that
oh sorry what was your question Sarah I
didn't catch that I think I think
Johnson himself has now handed over a
whole load of messages yeah Boris
Johnson has disclosed uh all of his
WhatsApp messages today and notebooks
and Diaries and handed them over to the
cabinet office in fact he was um
extremely Cooperative in that statement
that was released by his spokesperson Uh
Kevin what did you make of Boris
Johnson's cooperation today and you know
seemingly it heaps a lot more pressure
on the cabinet office to hand over all
the material
he did he's made them look Chumps uh the
ghost of Boris Johnson's returned to
Horn Rishi sudak and the cabinet
ministers yet again
because he says urgently disclosed Boris
Johnson given the lock maybe he realizes
he hasn't got much of a reputation to
lose anymore that nothing can really be
there any more damage him than we've
seen and Dominic Cummings uh disclosed
some of his WhatsApp messages I remember
when they fell out spectacularly uh Matt
Hancock's WhatsApp messages were made
clear but the cabinet office was in this
ridiculous position where it said well
we haven't got the messages but there's
nothing really in them anyway Move Along
please nothing to see here uh but now
Johnson's handed them over and said pass
them on I think they'll have to climb
down and pass them on and Heather
Hallett the chair of the committee will
will get her way which the guardian
quotes William ragger Tory MP who chairs
the uh all-party constitutional Affairs
committee say look the law is on her
side anyway the government set up the
Inquirer she has a power to ask for
whatever she wants and Johnson appears
to be playing ball which I think is the
right position because he will be aware
I'm sure that if Hallett went to to law
went to court to demand the disclosure
of these no books and WhatsApp messages
she would have won and the cabinet
office would have lost so I think the
cabinet offers with Oliver Dowden and
the cabinet office minister in in the
cabinet there a deputy prime minister as
lost and as uh egg on his face Sarah I
can I can see you're nodding is there
something you want to add there
well I mean there's there's a there's a
there's no love lost between Oliver
Dowden and Johnson but also I think that
Johnson's calculation is probably that
because these messages will involve a
lot of people including where she's
sunak including this truss including
Dominic Cummings including Simon case
um that you know this if they're
disclosed that you know it may it may
help transfer some it will give a bigger
picture for him but also it may take the
heat slightly out of him because they
will inevitably have have said things in
the Heat of the Moment uh you know and
it was very difficult feverish time
kovid
um there were lots of brows and
arguments going on uh people were losing
their temper and saying things off the
cuff so it will you know it may actually
Pace it may be place at Johnson's favor
to have these messages
um exposed they will of course be leaked
I mean it's almost inevitable that they
will believe because everything is sleep
so you know that we have to be prepared
for that
um and and you know that was possibly
one of the reasons why uh the cabinet
office was so reluctant to let uh before
I have them in the first place because
inevitably they will come out into the
open and certainly what's that message
is uh people are perhaps a lot more
casual in the way they use them you're a
bit more careful about what you put in
an email let's see what happens tomorrow
uh let's move on to the front page of
the I Kevin uh their analysis on their
front page tomorrow shows that Labor's
new policies would cost the same as a 3p
hike in income tax your take on this
yeah I think this is going to be the
first of many stories on Labor's
spending program at Kia storm or way
ahead in the polls what's full form the
next government looks like he will be
probably the next prime minister of uh
of our country and I think it's a
legitimate and justifiable to begin uh
scrutinizing Labor's proposals and the I
reckon the spending uh plans so far on
free child care foreign aid School
breakfast and police tell about 20
billion pound which The Institute for
fiscal studies say is equivalent of 3p
on income tax isn't mean income tax will
go up three people that's the the
equivalent and latest tax proposals at
the moment really ended the non-dom uh
uh loophole I would call it and put VAT
on private school fees would raise about
five billion so that's a 15 billion Gap
now labor-made dispute the figures but
uh we're going to get more and more
scrutiny racial Reeves Pat McFadden and
the treasury team have been pretty
strong on spending uh plans and uh you
know to the annoyance of many of the
company uh Shadow cabinet members who
want to unveil uh goodies to be told
they can't but those they have they will
have to show how they fund them labor
often gets this tougher than the Tories
um mainly because I suppose we've got
Tori prayer Tory press or Tori leaning
press but at the same time I think it's
quite legitimate that laborer comes
another Spotlight as well yeah so a
brief thought from you on this I think
we're going to see more and more
scrutiny um and crunch the numbers when
it comes to Labor's promises ahead of
the election if it's far easier being in
opposition than it is being in power
yeah and I think that's right as Kevin
says it's important that we delve you
know we get into the weeds of this stuff
but I mean the Tories have also got
their financial woes and the other front
pages that we've seen you know this
whole row about inheritance tax
um the vice chancellors complaining that
they haven't got enough money to run
their universities that you know money
is a big problem for both parties
regardless of who's in power
um and you know the the labor party are
going to have to come up with a really
cogent plan to persuade the public that
they can manage things better than the
Tories I mean the Tories
yeah there is a there are wider factors
causing the financial problems that ft
has got a very interesting leader today
about uh the issues in China and China's
Financial ways the whole world you know
China Germany is a recession the whole
world has got money problems yeah um and
navigating your way out of that is going
to be difficult yeah certainly there's
not much to go around in the coffers and
that leads us neatly onto the front page
of the Daily Telegraph Kevin uh on this
very issue of inheritance tax uh Rishi
sunak facing pressure to scrap it from
his own MPS
yeah they managed to get 50 uh or more
than 50 MPS I say pretty Town Nadine
zawari Jacob wrist smog I would say the
usual suspect on the right to the
conservative party uh to claim it's
unfair they're launching a campaign now
basically I think they were fairness
with inheritance taxes it isn't a lot
higher there's only some percent of the
states uh uh actually pay it some
percent of what what's that about one in
14 uh an individual can leave uh half a
million tax free to people that's really
something for nothing couples are a
billion pound it's a seven billion seven
billion is raised which uh Jacob Reese
smogs has a modest amount well what
you're going to cut how are you going to
fund that 7 billion now I think it
should be higher George Osborne did say
he would raise it in 2007 and he helped
derail a labor or a general election
then that Gordon Brown was contemplating
the 2010 Tory election Manifesto said
they've raised a limit and and didn't
did didn't if there are taxes to cut
it's not inheritance tax because I think
it's the fairest tax of all because
shrouds have no pockets you can't take
it with you it's maybe graveyards are
full of rich people but it is a real
welfare state you get something for
nothing if you inherit the person who
create that money is dead they've gone
but you are getting something you're
very lucky if you do get something but I
really think you should pay tax on it
and while we're on this discussion of
funding Kevin let's get a thought from
you Sarah if I may on the front page of
the Guardian uh Vice Chancellor's
warning that the funding model for UK
universities is broken
can I just come back to Kevin on the
inheritance tax thing very briefly which
is that it's the problem is that people
it's it's houses it's people's houses so
people can buy a house for very little
and then because the property Market in
this country is so mad and so insane
they can find themselves sitting on a
lot of money that is basically the
amount of money that their house has
gone up in value so if you have these
high thresholds then what happens is
people have to sell their houses and
quite often they're not people who are
wealthy they're people who've just
bought a little house and now suddenly
it's worth five times what it was worth
that's the difference the property
Market anyway moving on the vice chances
they're bleeding because apparently they
haven't got enough money well can I just
say quite a lot of Vice chances are paid
an awful lot of money themselves some of
them are on about four hundred thousand
pounds a year not only that
students are getting the most appalling
value for money at the moment they pay
nine thousand pounds a year for as far
as I can see almost nothing they're
always lecturers are constantly on
strike uh you know they their
accommodation costs are Fortune there
why is a lot I mean there's this whole
route at the moment over some some
University finalists not being able to
actually get their final results because
they're not going to be marked before
they graduate which is insane I think
the whole university sector is in
trouble but I'm not entirely sure it's
just to do with funding I think it's to
do with mismanagement and the fact that
you know the vice chances are not doing
their job properly which is not really
just to sit around having nice dinners
with um subsidized wine it's actually to
sort of try and run these run these
organizations properly the problem also
they're crossed because they're not
going to get so many foreign students
which has been a huge source of uh money
for universities and you know that's
that's possibly right because they again
you know they've used foreign students
as cash cows for so long the whole thing
isn't a mess I'm sure Vice chancellors
would dispute some of what you said
there Sarah but certainly you make a
good point and we'll we'll give you both
a breather and speak to you in just a
moment coming up on the Press preview
ITV orders an external inquiry into the
circumstances surrounding Philip
schofield's departure we'll be
discussing that next day with us
[Music]
foreign
McGuire and Sarah Vine to review the
papers this evening let's kick off uh
with your front page Uh Kevin the mirror
leading on the Schofield row certainly
really interesting uh what we learned
today about ITV calling in an external
review and I thought um it was quite
interesting that we learned the chief
executive Dame Carolyn McCall has said
has said that there's been a lot of
inaccuracy in recent reporting why do
you think it's taken ITV so long to
clarify that
well I suspect they uh we're hoping to
Bunker down and it would go away and it
hasn't uh not least because a lot of
aggrieved former uh presenters and so on
are sharpening axes and settling scores
and it's it's captured of public
imagination here so they had no
alternative uh I believe particularly
given uh they'll be grilled next week by
MPS to get an inquiry going and getting
the Barrister is a I think it's a smart
move by ITV Carolyn mccort that is
quoted on the uh from the mirror saying
we feel badly let down because Schofield
admitted they he lied that she said that
as recently as a month ago we've been
told about no no affair
clearly the internal inquiry in 2020 if
that's when it was uh didn't didn't
uncover that he didn't uncover the truth
and you set up an inquiry it's it's not
in the long grass but you get something
from the outside or go through all the
records because we interview some people
uh and then we'll come up with
conclusions but
the problem in the longer term is you
can lose control of an inquiry I
remember Dominic Robb Deputy Prime
Minister said he was happy to have a
barrister investigate claims he'd been
fully and sold servants well found out
he had been bullying civil servants and
he lost his job
so it'll be it'll be some people
sweating in an ITV undoubtedly
Sarah your thoughts on all of this The
Daily Mail also leading uh with this uh
story tomorrow describing ITV is
humiliated on on their front page and
forced to order uh this inquiry
yeah I mean I think it's just
interesting the way the whole thing has
unraveled you know remember Scofield
coming out as gay and him being a hero
and Holly hugging and all of that sort
of stuff and and it's it's sort of
spiraled into a a sort of much darker
story really and I think that um
it's it it's it's about power in the
workplace isn't it and it's about what
people feel they can and cannot say and
it's about whether you can uh stand up
to somebody if you think they're doing
the wrong thing if they're very Superior
to you it's it's a sort of it's quite a
human story in that respect and there
are lots of people
um in workplaces who who maybe do see
things that they they're not comfortable
with but they're too scared to say
anything because they don't want to lose
their jobs or because the person
concerned is very senior so there's that
that you know and and the thing about
Schofield was that he was seemingly
Invincible he was the the guy and nobody
could say anything to him
um and it does have Echoes of past
scandals uh of this nature so uh yeah
we'll have to wait and see what happens
uh I think I always think inquiries are
double-edged swords as Kevin was saying
because well a lot of them are sort of
in a way a way for people the people in
charge who should have been responsible
sort of passing the buck
um but also they don't always turn up
the results that you want
and of course ITV bosses are likely to
be quizzed by MPS on this uh Scandal
next week Kevin what do you make of um
politicians wading in
given the state of Parliament and
political parties and there's an amusing
cyber saying that they also represent uh
represent as they are elected
representatives but ITV now go before
that uh committee it was a long-standing
routine it wasn't about this but of
course it's gonna it's gonna crop up
they can now say there's an inquiry and
they can deflect questions to some
extent if there wasn't an inquiry by a
barrister they would have to answer more
detailed questions so it's you know the
the timing is very is very opposite for
uh for ITV and I'm sure it's part of the
part was part of their thinking now uh
Carolyn McCall said in her letter to
which went to of calm and the chair of
the culture committee and the culture
secretary so they would share the
findings of this report okay sorry to
wrap you there Kevin I thought you'd
enjoy that question see you both in a
moment thanks very much